Now,
is apple willing to share that with you?
I mean,
when you,
when you're talking about biometrics,
fingerprints or face,
no,
not the,
not the data.
It's just the operating system verifies that there's an individual as an
individual and it's unlocking,
you know,
like,
um,
you know,
when,
when you use the,
um,
our,
our cash app uses us,
right?
So squares,
cash app,
um,
when you want to make a transfer to someone,
when you want to send someone money or when you want to buy Bitcoin,
we turn on face id and you verify that you are you and you are the owner of the
phone and then it goes,
we don't get images of your face.
We don't see who you are.
Oh,
that's what you want me to think.
I know
that's how locked down by the operating system and that's what it should be.
Right?
Sure.
Um,
what,
has there ever been any consideration to not allowing people to post
anonymously?
Well,
let's see.
I like what you said earlier about journalists and whistle blowers.
That is political.
So look at a look at platforms that have a real names policy look at Facebook,
right?
Or the problems that need different.
I don't know cause I don't go there but for I understand there's a lot of,
still a lot of arguing there.
It's the same at a political argument,
the same vectors,
same patterns.
It's like older in general it seems.
I also am not really hanging out there but it seems a little bit older.
It's a lot of grammys looking at pictures of their kids,
grandkids and stuff.
And that's what it was made for it,
it's connecting,
it's connecting with the people that you know and,
and that to me is the biggest difference for Twitter.
It's connecting with the people you don't know.
When you find interesting and like it's around,
it's around topics and stuff that you find a,
that you want to learn more about.
When you saw Zuckerberg testifying and in realizing like how this platform is
being used and what are the dangers of this.
And then you see these senators that really don't know what the fuck the
technology is or it's w w it really highlights how we're entering into this.
Really.
Yeah.
Well not just a gap,
a gap in the critical understanding of how these things work and what they are
in in terms of like how these really important politicians who are the ones who
are making these decisions as to whether or not someone has violated laws or
whether or not something should be curbed or regulated.
They don't really even understand what they're talking about.
No,
I mean there's,
there's a few people do because they're not,
they're not using it directly.
They're not using in the way that people are using it every single day and don't
have the same experience that people have every single day.
And you know,
in,
in terms of regulatory and our regulators and our governments,
I,
you know,
we,
I think the conversation is often about how regulators will come in and start
writing rules and,
and setting expectations for how companies or services might behave.
But there's a role for the company to educate and there's a role for the company
to educate on like what technology makes possible,
whether it be positive and also some of the negatives that that become possible
as well.
So I think we have a role to,
to help educate and to,
and to help make sure that we're,
you know,
really we're,
we're,
we're pushing towards what I think the job of regular regulator is,
which is number one,
protect the individual number to level the playing field and make sure that
those two things are not compromised by special interests trying to protect
their own domain or profits or,
or,
uh,
dominance within a particular market.
What do you mean by level?
The playing field of the playing field so that a individual has the same
opportunity,
uh,
that,
someone else might have,
our company might have.
So,
okay.
So like anybody who went to account,
anyone can have a Twitter account and you know,
they have,
uh,
at least,
you know,
an equal opportunity to contribute to it.
And whatever they do with it will change the,
change the outcome.
Some people might become very popular because they're saying stuff people want
to hear.
Some people won't see any following whatsoever because they're not adding
anything original or interesting or,
or,
uh,
we're,
we're different in terms of perspective.